We give zero fucks.
Your Ratha drove,
rode to the experience.
Do you know that that was Sarah Palin?
She said that Sarah Pailin had a conversation with a librarian and was Cilla
Alaska where she said that on the Internet there was a photograph of,
of human footprint inside of dinosaur footprint.
And the woman,
like the woman like talked about this and Sarah Palin was running for president
or vice president,
whatever.
And she was like,
what?
Pause the
fuck.
Like this is a woman that got that a heartbeat away from being the president.
And she thought she thought that dinosaurs and humans walk together
and then you see people who are intelligent.
Yeah.
We'll get that pee pill that down.
Brian claim dinosaurs of people coexist and amazing cause it say they're about
the librarian.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
whatever.
Well,
and I think that,
um,
uh,
what's the other one?
I'm not Sarah Palin.
Yeah.
Michele Bachman.
Michele Bachmann's worse.
Well her husband's Gay,
right?
Is Gay,
is gay.
As Gay,
as gay as the day is beautiful and long and flower smell pretty and butterflies
are beautiful.
That guy's gay.
I let you,
he can suck enough dick.
There's no way.
If you could just just give him a free pass.
If you ever got that guy liquored up and put a heart on in front of him,
he would jump on it.
Like Greg Louganis off the top peer swan dive on that.
His head would be spinning a out of a gain and he'd still get some tongue on the
shaft.
He would automatically start salivating to the point where it was like a
waterfall coming out of his mouth pouring down his shirt.
Just so alive.
Long story,
you would know where the pool started and the saliva for Dick starts coming out
of it.
Yeah,
it would literally be like a saliva waterfall and like when not when people have
a backyard and they have those really like,
like fancy little rock formations where the water comes down into their pool.
If you're really fancy schmancy.
That was his mouth.
Yeah.
If he,
he would say to a young man,
do you want to go in the hot tub with me?
And the guy would go,
okay,
they'd get in the hot tub and the guy we go,
there's no water in here,
and he'd go,
just wait,
let me see your cock
warm and gooey.
It's comes out 96 degrees.
I'd let them blow me if I knew that I could take down Michelle Bachmann
particular down.
From what though?
Just because she will be an elected leader.
Joe,
you really feel that?
I know.
So lucky.
You just have to see who fox news is trotting out and she is one of the first
pundits they go to for comments on shit.
She is introducing legislation in Congress right now that is actually being
enacted.
So what's the stopper?
Me,
I will suck her husband's deck and release it on the,
on the Internet.
I'll take the hit.
All we need to do is
get them on some ecstasy.
Right?
Just get them to realize the folly of his ways.
It's like these people that are like that.
I guarantee you if you got them on some ecstasy and gave him a hug and go
fucking don't worry about it man.
Don't worry about it.
I know who you are.
Just let it go be.
You don't,
don't be gobble,
gobble,
gobble.
Yeah.
Just grabbing them and stuffing them in.
This Steph it ed party up.
Dude,
you're already like 60.
He's probably actually probably having a lot of gay sex.
He's just not telling her dad he's having a lot of gay sex.
And I think it's similar with a lot of celebrities.
I don't want to mention names like say Oprah,
like her husband,
I believe.
How dare you?
I believe um,
eats.
I've heard rumors.
He always have to substantiate things like that.
I've heard rumors that he looks extremely gay.
To me.
I would say those rumors automatically.
Um,
if I knew that there was a woman out there or a man out there,
brother whose girlfriend makes $100 billion,
I would say that guy's gay.
Right?
Fucking right out of the gate.
You're,
your Dick would get so small from being around that much money every day and
it's not yours.
She is so dominant over him.
And what does that guy do?
Is you make a hundred grand a year.
I mean,
who knows what the fuck he does.
I think he goes out and does well,
here's,
here's the cash in for doing nothing is the,
he does speeches like they pay him to come in and do motivational speeches.
Oh God.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
That's hilarious.
Motivational speeches.
Yeah,
whatever you would do.
This is how you find a really which powerful woman and just connect to her.
That's [inaudible] people look,
who knows?
Maybe the guys are really brilliant,
intelligent guy.
Maybe it doesn't give a fuck about money.
Maybe he's just enlightened.
No,
it's true.
Actually.
I know dudes that are like that,
that are with really strong women and they are totally cool with it.
They,
they find them and you know,
in chanting and humorous and they go for the ride.
That's fine.
I guess for us we're kind of Alpha males,
so I think it would be difficult for us to picture of being in the backseat
maybe and maybe not.
I think there's,
it's really hard when you say like that this would work or that would work
generalizing because there's people in my life that on paper I shouldn't like
hmm.
And I fucking love them.
You know what I mean?
This relationships that I've had with people that despite all the craziness,
I enjoyed the fuck out of my time with them and you know,
and sometimes in a more intense way,
even though it wasn't like,
it wasn't anything that had legs like they could actually lasts.
Like,
cause after a while you have real relationships where you could actually go on
vacation with someone.
Right.
Do you remember when you first started going vacation with girlfriends and like
three or four days and you're like,
oh my God,
I need a jump out of a fucking window now.
Right?
Oh,
I had a girl that I faked a phone call.
My friend called me up.
I faked an obligation to get rid of her.
She came to stay with me for the weekend,
just for the weekend and two days in she was complaining about everything to the
point where it's was like there was no fun to be had.
Everything was just a complaint,
complaining about the music,
complaining about where we're going to go to eat,
complaining about every fucking thing.
And it was,
I was panicking.
My friend called me up and,
and I,
and I go,
hey,
what's up man?
And I go,
oh dude,
I forgot shit.
Fuck,
I got to come get you all.
My God,
I'm so sorry.
This is my friend Johnny who's quite a slit character.
It was like,
oh,
I can it.
What's going on?
What are you doing over there?
And I go,
Bethany's here.
Shit.
Is that her name?
Damn.
A nice person.
But it was the wrong time for both of us.
Look,
I was a fucking pain in the ass then too.
That was part of the problems.
Like I was a fucking,
I think that's it too.
I think that when you're a young man,
I think it'd be hard for you to travel with anybody but other young men,
you just,
you are a fucking explore.
You want to really go nuts and
yeah.
Not only that,
you're dumb.
Yeah.
I was 20,
I was 24,
I think it was maybe 23 at the time.
I was so stupid.
Yeah.
I mean it was so sick and crazy and it was doing me like two years removed from
fighting.
So my brain was hardwired the wrong way.
Like I had to rewire it.
My brain was,
was wired for violent competition and then breaks in between that.
Like that was my whole life.
So going from that to like the like being around girls and relationships and
trying to manage those waters was very confusing for me because,
but fighting was such like a solitary pursuit.
Right.
I had a,
I used to keep journals,
uh,
up until probably when I was like 23 or something,
but I was dating this girl and we went to Europe together.
Uh,
it was like after Sophomore Year of college that summer she had,
she had studied abroad in,
in Austria for the second semester.
So I saved us some cash and I flew over there and we met in London and we went
to Ireland and we went to France and I was fucking miserable and I was keeping a
journal and I look back at it now and it wasn't her,
it was just that like I just wanted to do my own fucking thing.
I wasn't into negotiating and compromising because at that age you feel like
life is so short,
you don't want to waste a day.
You just feel like whatever the most exciting thing is,
that's what you want to be doing.
And that's often not what comes out in the copy.
There's definitely that.
But this is also,
I was just selfish.
Yeah.
I didn't want to do what anybody else.
Well I think that's what we're both saying.
I mean,
but it wasn't even that I was thinking,
Hey,
life is short.
It wasn't a romantic,
it was like totally egotistical.
You know?
Like if you look back,
like if you had to go back in time and be yourself when you were 23 or 22 years
old,
like what a fucking mess that would be.
Like you'd be like,
ah,
what do I have to deal with?
Yeah.
You know,
you would like look at the relationships that you'd try to manage.
Like what the fuck mess you created and that you're just such a different human
now than you were then.
You spend so much energy on relationships back then.
I'll tell you man,
having like a relationship,
like a special,
like when you were 16 the amount emotionally I grew from like 16 to like 18
which was during the term that I had this girl as a girlfriend.
She was a very nice person too.
She was,
she was not a mean nasty in any way,
which was really nice as well.
Like I dated some girls after that were,
they were mean and nasty and when it will first time a girl in salt you,
it's like,
it's a weird thing,
you know,
because like sh this.
My first girlfriend never would do that.
She was very smart as well and like we would have conversations,
they were interesting conversations,
but there was no manipulation.
There's no weirdness.
And then I dated this girl about a year later that was the opposite.
She was very nice.
She was very pretty unfortunately for her because it gave her this fucking,
this ability to list constantly have men around her constantly have people
hitting on her.
But she knew how to fuck with you and like you would see it happened.
She would say something like he was your nose always that crooked.
And I was just going to what?
Like,
I don't know.
And then I remember thinking,
what the fuck was that like,
Ooh,
what's going on here?
Yeah.
She would say shit like that.
Like all the time,
you know?
Yeah.
Weird Shit.
And that's where you see bad marriages is when,
when either person and salts,
the other one it's like,
unless it's,
you really get that,
that's their stack and they fuck around and bust each other's balls.
Right.
But when you see the guy get a little bit,
you know,
damaged by it,
you just think God,
ah,
the
girl,
the girl getting damaged out of it,
he has even more like tension because there's a physical violence worry,
you know,
obviously you know women do violence on men.
I mean I lost a very good friend and Phil Hartman for that very thing.
His wife shot him while I was in his sleep and that was a horrible relationship
and that was a relationship where his ex wife used to do subtle shit to insult
him in front of large groups of people.
Like she would chew chip him down because she was a failed actress and you know,
Phil was a superstar,
was coming up Saturday night live.
He's constantly movies and you know,
he was just a,
well like a deeply loved guy.
And so she would take,
he would take her to parties and she would take that opportunity to assault him
in front of people,
like in real subtle ways like acuity.
We're talking about cars because Phil was like a car nut and he bought a Ferrari
and he was so happy he bought this car.
Like he saved up his money and he's like a big deal for him.
He saved his money,
made from a couple of movies and he always wanted one of these things.
And the way he would talk about it,
like he was a very interesting guy,
very,
very smart,
smoked weed and it would get like real crazy about shit,
like really into things and have these wild conversations and like kid who's a
really,
like he loved things.
He loved becoming a pilot.
Like he became a pilot while we were doing news radio.
And I remember seeing them sitting there like studying due to flee all these
aviation books.
I'm way to add for that,
right?
But this guy would study and like his lines,
like when we had a scene,
he would study his lines over and over and over and over.
And he was sitting like a consummate professional and Lee Scott.
So when he was talking about this Ferrari,
it was about the Italian engineering and the shape of it and the sound of the
engine.
The whole experience was everything he had just,
and so she goes,
I like trucks.
You know,
my ex boyfriend had a truck,
my boyfriend's back home had trucks.
And so what is he thinking when he,
what do I hear?
What I hear is she's talking about these dudes who were probably truck I
pictured truck.
I've picture brutish men,
right?
Gorilla fucking her in the back of this truck.
Just throwing some hay down,
ripping her pants off and just fucking send it in.
It's not alone.
Of course,
this isn't fucking,
there's a line of dude's ropes,
fucking stirrups on shit.
But she would say that kind of shit.
You know,
she would always make jokes about him being old or make various jokes about
whatever.
You know,
she was trying to chip them down about,
but I'll never forget that.
You know,
I like trucks.
All my ex boyfriend's back home had trucks.
He's like,
yeah,
that's just a gross thing to say.
Yeah.
And you get that from your parents.
I mean,
they model it for you.
How you're going to treat your spouse is like,
I see it every fucking time.
I was hanging out with a friend a couple of nights ago and the parents were
around the,
his,
uh,
his inlaws were around and I could see the way they treat each other.
I was like,
Oh yeah,
that's your marriage.
That's how your wife,
Oh,
it's so true.
So my parents,
like,
they really respected each other.
Like they never,
they never did that.
They kicked it around a lot,
but it was so obviously fun what they were doing.
And they really respected each other.
They never took shots in public.
And when they had to,
if they had to have a serious discussion and it wasn't yelling,
they would wait till we went to bed.
They go on the other side of the house,
closed the door,
and we heard muffled,
you know?
Whereas like some people just Sir fucking argument in front of their kids,
it's like,
well,
that's what your kids are going to do when they grow up.
Yeah.
That's,
that's super important,
man.
It's super important to show them the model of what's possible and if you're in
a bad relationship,
it's just as equally important to get out.
Right.
One of the really important things my mother taught me when I was a little kid
is getting out of a relationship.
When we were five,
she moved to Sim with my grandmother,
and then we got an apartment.
We moved out of my dad's place because her and my dad were involved in this,
a abusive relationship.
So I remember thinking that like,
wow,
like my mom was smart.
She does the right thing.
When Shit goes wrong,
she doesn't just take it.
She has options out.
She figures a way out of it,
even with two kids,
you know?
So it took a lot of courage to do,
I was going to say balls,
but that's ridiculous.
Okay.